it's pleasure to be here with you today
I'm Ken Cuccinelli head of the United
States Citizenship and Immigration
Services and president Trump has once
again delivered on his promise to the
American people to enforce long-standing
immigration law today USCIS the agency I
had as part of the Department of
Homeland Security has issued a rule that
encourages and ensures self-reliance and
self-sufficiency for those seeking to
come to or to stay in the United States
it will also help promote immigrant
success in the United States as they
seek opportunity here throughout our
history self-reliance has been a core
principle in America the virtues of
perseverance hard work self-sufficiency
laid the foundation of our nation and
have defined generations of immigrants
seeking opportunity in the United States
our current law which is generations old
recognizes that some new arrivals to our
country need the help of their family
and community it requires some of those
who seek to live and remain in the
United States to have a sponsor who will
be financially responsible for them case
of my own family my Italian grandfather
played this role sponsoring two of his
cousins Mario and Silvio to come to
America once they arrived my grandfather
wanted to make sure his cousins spoke
English certainly well enough to work
and enlisted my father in that effort as
well to make sure they could speak
English well enough to work and they did
my family worked together to ensure that
they could provide for their own needs
and they never expected the government
to do it for them and this same
hard-working spirit shared by countless
immigrants who've made the u.s. their
home is central to our American identity
the spirits also been rooted for over a
century well over a century in our
immigration laws going back to the 1800s
since 1996 the law has required foreign
nationals to rely on their own
capabilities and the resources of their
families
sponsors and private organizations in
their communities to succeed however
Congress has never defined the term
public charge in the law and that term
hadn't been clearly defined by
regulation well that is what changes
today with this rule through the public
charge rule president Trump's
administration is reinforcing the ideals
of self-sufficiency and personal
responsibility ensuring that immigrants
are able to support themselves and
become successful here in America our
rule generally prevents aliens who are
likely to become a public charge from
coming to the United States or remaining
here in getting a green card public
charge is now defined in a way that
ensures the law is meaningfully enforced
and that those who are subject to it are
self-sufficient under the rule a public
charge is now defined as an individual
who receives one or more designated
public benefits for more than 12 months
in the aggregate within any 36 month
period for instance receipt of two
different benefits in one month counts
as two months a public charge in
admissibility determination is
prospective and looks at whether an
individual is likely at any point in the
future to become a public charge as we
define it in the regulation public
benefits are defined as federal state
and local as well as tribal cash
assistance for income maintenance and a
small list of non-cash benefits some
examples of the public benefits that are
part of the rule are general assistance
SSI snap most forms of Medicaid and
certain subsidized housing programs
significantly the rule does not consider
many forms of government assistance that
protect children and pregnant woman's
health as public benefits generally this
includes emergency medical assistance
disaster relief
national school lunch programs WIC chip
Medicaid received by people under the
age of 21 or pregnant women as well as
foster care and adoption subsidies
student and mortgage loans energy
assistance food pantries homeless
shelters and Head Start it's important
to note this rule will apply
prospectively only to applications and
petitions received starting on October
15th of this year once this rule is
implemented and effective on October
15th
USCIS carreer Immigration Services
offered officers what we call is OS
we'll generally consider an aliens
current and past receipt of the
designated public benefits while in the
United States as a negative factor when
examining applications however receipt
of certain non-cash benefits received
before October 15th will not be
considered as a negative factor the
underlying statute passed on a
bipartisan basis also requires officers
to assess at a minimum each applicants
age health family status assets
resources and financial status and their
education and skills as well as other
factors set forth in the rule in the
totality of the circumstances the
totality of the circumstances means that
officers will assess all of the evidence
related to these factors and no one
factor alone will decide an applicants
case most of these factors are the ones
Congress mandated us to review when
considering immigration benefit
applications under this final rule USCIS
will be able to objectively determine
whether an applicant is likely at any
time in the future to receive public
benefits above the designated threshold
importantly this final rule has no
impact on humanitarian
based immigration programs for refugees
and asylees no impact on refugees or
asylees and it clarifies the exemption
for trafficking victims and victims of
domestic violence
Congress has long carved out exemptions
for these categories and our regulation
adhere strictly to the laws as written
the final rule also excludes from
consideration public benefits received
by certain members of the US Armed
Forces and their spouses and children as
well as Medicaid benefits for emergency
medical services lastly under the final
rule USCIS can permit an applicant
seeking a green card from inside the
United States who's inadmissible only on
the public charge ground to adjust their
status to that of a legal permanent
resident if they will post a public
charge bond so to conclude I just note
again that generations of immigrants
have strengthened the foundation of our
country but in making positive
contributions today and we expect that
to continue in the future through
faithful execution of our nation's
long-standing laws president Trump's
public charge inadmissibility rule
better ensures that immigrants are able
to successfully support themselves as
they seek opportunity here in America
throughout our history Americans and
legal immigrants have pulled themselves
up by their bootstraps to pursue their
dreams and the opportunity of this great
nation as president Trump delivers on
his promise to uphold the rule of law
this administration is promoting our
shared history and encouraging the core
values needed to make the American dream
a reality and with that I'm happy to
take some questions yes sir
as you know the primary focus of this
president throughout his presidency has
been on illegal immigration a focus of
what you just outlined in this proposed
rule yes this is not a change in focus
this rule goes all the way back to
executive orders from early in 2017
it's been a long arduous effort
if you take a look at the fully printed
item it'll it'll it'll make worn piece
seem relatively short it is very
thorough in the first attempt to to put
in to operational effect all the
different factors that Congress itself
has said we're supposed to consider when
deciding admissibility or
inadmissibility I would also note as the
head of the agency responsible for
naturalizing citizens the step after
legal permanent residency for many
people last year we we swore in more
American citizens than the four years
before it and this year I expect to see
similar numbers again so we've not at
all laid off of in the Trump
administration processing properly legal
immigration I think what you you've seen
and heard more discussion of illegal
immigration but we've been pressing
ahead and this rule is an example of
that yes ma'am
illegal immigration by legislation
absolutely not
absolutely not this is an implementation
of a law passed by Congress in 1996 that
has not been given a meaningful effect
1999 some guidance was put in place with
a presumption a rule would follow the
rule never followed and so today we're
issuing a rule which as I said for the
first time really puts meaningful meat
on the bones of the 1996 law passed on a
bipartisan basis this does not
substitute does not substitute for
congressional action in other areas for
instance acai I mentioned asylees are
not covered by this rule asylum is a
major subject of focus for us in our in
Maya agency and with the crisis at the
border
we've been all but begging Congress to
take action to close the loophole some
of them the same as the Obama
administration that has not happened so
in this narrow area of our
responsibility we're relying on
congressional direction and we've as I
said put meat on the bones here I think
today yes sir they're being processed in
the ordinary course of business we're
working on other things within the
agency right now but I'm not prepared to
speak to where those may end up today
sorry so you did say to all right there
were recently workplace immigration
rates and of course President Trump his
first person commutation went to a man
who was arrested after his business
failed
ventured legal immigrants were arrested
did that decision to prince prison
commutation I'm not really prepared to
speak to that I don't think so the
president does those one person at a
time I think what you saw is due this
week and enforcing the law meaningfully
with seven operations across the state
of Mississippi on out course
investigations still ongoing criminal
investigations growing out of that is a
is a growth for ice from the previous
year their enforcement efforts are up
and I think you can expect to see more
of that as part of the message of this
administration we're going to enforce
the law yes sir he might be afraid to
apply is do that's an excellent question
with the receipt by a citizen in the
household of public benefits will not
effect the consideration for a
particular alien as a general matter so
the citizens in that household again in
their receipt of public benefits don't
effect consideration of an alien as
general matter we if you look at just
the first page of this rule you'll see
we start out by pointing out the things
that are not covered and we will have on
the USCIS website now and forevermore a
clear listing of the two so anyone who
has any question about whether the
receipt of a particular benefit would be
considered in a consideration for
instance if they applied for a green
card will be able to easily find that
from from our website and it is part of
the message we're broadcasting it's why
I talked to you and listed so many of
the items we don't cover I hope you all
will cover that as well yes ma'am
Yeah right so I'm new to this this will
be it for two questions and we're gonna
go to one but I said yes you go ahead
almost as long the words at the base of
the Statue of Liberty that breathe give
us your tired your poor you were
implementing a public charge rule for
the first time is that sentiment give us
your tired your poor still operative in
the United States should those words
come down well I'm certainly not
prepared to take anything down off the
Statue of Liberty we we have a long
history of being one of the most
welcoming nations in the world on a lot
of bases whether you be in a sily
whether you be coming here to join your
family or immigrating yourself this rule
will cover for USCIS almost four hundred
thousand people a year whose
applications to become legal permanent
residents will include a meaningful
analysis of whether they're likely to
become a public charge or not I do not
think by any means we're ready to take
anything off the Statute of Liberty yes
ma'am millions of Americans who for
example so why is that different for
someone who's in this country legally
who's struggling to you know have
certain needs so the benefit to
taxpayers is a long-term benefit of
seeking to ensure that our immigration
system is bringing people to join us as
American citizens as legal permanent
residents first who can stand on their
own two feet who will not be reliant on
the welfare system especially in the age
of the modern welfare state which is so
expansive and expensive frankly so that
is that self sufficiency that has been a
central part of the American value set
for so long is critical for us and for
taxpayers going forward that's part of
the motivation
for a rule like this it's part of the
benefit that goes all the way back 140
years this rule as I said earlier simply
puts meat on the bones of that
consideration yes sir no because the the
the benefit for taxpayers is for is in
the is forward-looking the costs we do
that you'll see in this rule are a cost
of implementation they're not the
benefits in having more American
citizens 5 10 20 30 years down the road
who are more self-sufficient and less
dependent on the welfare states yes sir
how much will the case officers have
when they're kind of seeing this so
obviously said will have a negative
score application but will the
caseworkers still be able to say John a
I know you took this benefit for you all
still be eligible for green card or is
it pretty much you know sorry that's
just no that's an excellent question
this is a totality of circumstances test
it means that the welfare benefits we've
been talking about here are one factor I
listed the others that Congress has
itself put in the statute things like
age health we basically rely for health
on the legally required medical exam but
it is career Immigration Services
officers that are going to be making
these decisions and they're going to
have to weigh all these factors together
the change under this rule is we're
finally giving guidance that brings all
those factors together that really
hasn't been effectively done up until
today yes ma'am plan to admit in 2020
and also are you considering eliminating
the refugee refugee program altogether I
can't imagine anyone would ever consider
eliminating the refugee program
altogether and Congress would have to do
that anyway
the number for next year is needs to be
decided by the end of September by the
President and I don't have any insight
into what that number will be at this
point I'm saying this policy is unfairly
targeting the lower income
have you responded that well we
certainly expect people of any income to
be able to stand on their own two feet
and so if people are not able to be
self-sufficient then then this negative
factor is going to bear very heavily
against them in a decision about whether
they'll be able to become a legal
permanent resident and and a poor person
can be prepared to be self-sufficient
many have been through the history of
this country so let's not look at that
as the be-all and end-all it's not the
deciding factor which is why we continue
to use the totality of circumstances
test yes sir because I think use a lot
of a family that are in the country
legally they haven't yet gotten their
green cards they are in need of services
whether that be medical services whether
that be housing services to keep them
off the streets and they are going to
now be fearful of using the services to
which they are legally entitled under
the law because there's no way to
determine one two three years out from
when they might apply for their green
card you know whether how much they're
likely likely or not to get a green card
if they use the services so the fear is
that there will be a wave of people
across the country who will decide not
to get not to use the services sort of
affirmative ly that they're entitled to
out of fear that it'll ultimately come
to bite them way and how do you how do
you counter that if if in fact you want
them to use the services to which
they're entitled or is it or is this
really a sort of effort to say this is a
whole class of people that shouldn't
using any services well in your
description you described a situation
where government benefits were basically
in making allowing this family to hang
on that they're not self-sufficient and
while this if we go forward a few years
and look back at that situation because
remember we essentially start counting
October 15th with the exception of
things that would have qualified under
the 1999 guidance which is fairly narrow
then that's what we're trying to avoid
in the future now even under the
circumstances you describe if you're
talking about an applicant who has the
skills necessary to you know to make
their own way and to work their way out
of that situation that's a case they
make to the career caseworker
well Immigration Services officer but we
do want to avoid looking to the future a
situation where people who are adjusting
status do in the future become dependent
on those public benefits we're trying to
avoid that situation folks for a time so
so are you saying that if you're an
immigrant no I was using your example of
where they need them and and they
there's you know it's it's their
foundation financially as I took your
description and I would say that the the
entire legal immigration system is
designed by Congress for the benefit of
America and what we're looking for here
are people who are going to live with us
either their whole lives or ultimately
become citizens who can stand on their
own two feet with the same sort of
requirements that we've had in the past
for well over a century so yes sir in
the middle so not the benefits no but
the the use of benefits over the
12-month period in 36 months would be a
heavily negative factor there there are
negative factors heavily weighted
negative factors there are positive
factors heavily weighted positive
factors I'll give you an example the
other side if you have private health
insurance that is a heavily weighted
positive factor so those are those do
all weigh in again and the totality of
circumstances and obviously we call the
more heavily weighted factors heavily
because they matter more than the others
but they go in both directions yes sir
critics of the administration's
immigration policies before this seems
increasingly we're hearing from us
Catholic Bishops we're showing their
concern now you're Catholic when you
hear the bishops concern does it give
you any pause when you consider carrying
out some of these policies it doesn't
give me pause about implementing the
laws it's already been put in place and
particularly given the long history I
used an Italian example from my
background the other half is Irish so
you know I'm very familiar with what the
Catholic Bishops have to say on this
subject and they certainly are
vociferous and I would say as a Catholic
one of the things I'm proud of is that
my church has been one of the best
supporters of people in this country
before we had a welfare state so I don't
see that changing and I don't see any
conflict with enforcing the law as it's
written yes sir
[Music]
House of shooting you have the rates in
Mississippi but it's John noted before
you know the issues before we're if you
were here illegally now this obviously
extends the legal immigration why
shouldn't the Latino community feel
targeted by this well first of all this
is a hundred and forty year old legal
structure we're dealing with the most
recent iteration of it but this is not
new this was the same question might
have been asked when my Italian
immigrants were coming immigrant
ancestors were coming in and all through
that hundred and forty years so we're
we're not doing anything new here we're
simply making effective what Congress
had already put on the books so there's
no reason for any particular group to
feel like this is targeting them the so
apply across the world will apply to
more Latinos than any other likely well
if we'd been having this conversation
100 years ago they would have applied to
more Italians that were you know we can
go well that's just fine that well I
think that the divisive Natur achill and
I hope that you all in your role will
help cure that with some of how you
report it yes sir I'm gonna take two
more Orange
how many more imprints and silent
there's no there's no comprehensive
number out there at all the only things
with formal numbers are the earlier
question say about the annual refugee
number that happens every year
of course we're taking in I want to say
around a million plus a year right now
and I can't really speak to Joe Biden's
personal opinion but we don't have some
target number that we're working with
here that's your question all right last
question yes ma'am so what you would
normally have in the family circumstance
is you'd have an affidavit of support so
they wouldn't necessarily fall into the
category of being addressed by the
public charge rule because if they have
an affidavit of support which has been
scrutinized by USCIS officer and it is
believed that sponsor can in fact
support those identified at over a
hundred and twenty-five percent of the
federal poverty guidelines which is the
standard then that would be the end of
the discussion as it relates to that
sort of an application it's an excellent
question because it addresses a huge
piece of legal immigration in this
country thank you all very much